where did you meet robin we met at work
of course what what movie yeah no we met
on another life
and i was just gonna say another live
with justin chatwin
yeah with chatwin so you met me there
so was it the first day where you're
like i don't know if you're doing a
table read or
i don't know if you're on set and
there's this guy that walks in and
you're like
whoa i'm attracted to that guy and he
looks at you and all of a sudden it's
early
and you're like well i don't have many
scenes with him so we can kind of [ __ ]
around
i mean what is it he's not an actor so
like
whoa did he direct it no
no so robin um is a writer
um and one of his friends worked in the
production office
and he was looking for a way to
sort of like get back into the film
industry
and so he took a low level position on
our production
to sort of like get himself out of
managing a bar
and writing during the day it was a
cycle that he wasn't excited about he
was working all night and trying to
write during the day it was just
not the healthiest thing so he took this
job to have a normal
life in normal hours and you know we met
and i had nine months before gotten out
of a relationship that ended
so terribly and i had just
gotten to a point where i've gone
through therapy and i've accepted like
my part in it that was the star track
guy right
yeah we wanted to get in there what yeah
what was his name i forgot uh
carl carl carl right so yeah whatever
whatever just it just an
end great relationships mostly don't
didn't end great
you know what's funny it's it's it's um
well we didn't talk about it but
um so it had taken me a long time to get
to a point where i was like
all right and i truly thought that this
guy was gonna be a rebound um
because i was finally ready to
i was looking at men again like for the
first time in like nine months i was
like oh
he's cute he's cute right
feels good i really thought that i was
protecting myself because he's 10 years
younger than me and i was like
so he's 10. could you imagine
no michael he's 18. oh oh oh you're 28.
holy okay i get that but you know the
the thing i keep thinking about is
is he moving boxes on set is he saying
excuse me uh ma'am i'm just trying to
move the cables out here and you're like
oh god he's got great feet what
what was it he was a production
assistant
and and he you know he was just
we just became like best friends and
like i love those
really got to know each other on a
deeper level
um and that was all it was and then when
production was over
i just remember thinking myself i kept
saying to my mother like repeatedly
this guy's gonna make some woman so
happy one day
he is the most amazing person i've ever
met in my entire life wow
and i just kept saying that he's just so
smart he's so
kind like he's just like everything he's
amazing
wow he's gonna make some woman so happy
and my mom was like what is wrong with
you and i think i don't what are you
talking about
um and i was like oh no he's 10 years
younger than me she was like
i don't understand what is wrong with
you child wow so mom was a cheerleader
yeah yeah and i think that i think that
my mom was finally
um she saw someone that treated me well
and and um and that was that was
new wow yeah yeah
you know i think that she just went oh
my god this
this man is inherently kind